tata first of all congratulations on
bouncing back from yesterday's defeat
today she played the petrov did you
expect this were you happy with the
petrov seeing the petrov
uh yeah i was actually prepared for it
so my prep worked out well i don't know
why i played bishop c8 in the opening
but
i did what can i say and i just want to
tell you that you are my pick to
actually bounce today and go into the
tie breaks how are you going to approach
these tie breaks
uh i don't know i i don't have a very
good um score in tiebreaks in general
but um i'm the one who won the game so i
think i'm in better spirits than my
opponent hopefully when did you feel
you're taking over uh this game let's
take a look at the critical moments
should be here oh okay um
i just
felt like i was always better but i just
felt like i was losing the threat of the
position like i wasn't so sure here
anymore
yeah why is this hold on what did you
find at five here out of here
this was the six
this was the moment where we thought
that you could basically win the game
like this with this
there's a 97 wait why couldn't you go
rookie six perhaps queen g4 instead of
recap six rookies
and then we should have six i i beg your
parents device
this moment what do you mean i take
twice
i mean you've got queen g4 bishop f6
rookie 6 fp6 rook e6
queen g4
yes if you go bishop to f6 then i also
have uh nightwing h6 which wins on this
other spot that also is probably missing
the fact that i didn't see this
[Laughter]
oh yeah okay i didn't i didn't see this
yeah i mean i just felt like something
was i just wasn't finding it
so eventually yeah
a better major piece position but it was
very hard for you at this point yeah i
mean usually i'm on the worst side of
this as a french player so it was kind
of nice to be on the better side of it
you're right there's a french structure
exactly
here it was actually funny because we
got to a position
i know you've got a big game coming up
big playoff coming up and we thought
that you had found a great plan at
exactly this point which was to bring
your king to pizza yeah that was my plan
but then and we my plans changed yeah
exactly we thought for sure
we would have lost a bet we thought you
were going to go kingy want to bring
your teammates no that was that was my
plan but then i don't know i just i had
no time already and i was getting kind
of flustered and i was actually very
happy too because i've never done a king
run in the game before so i was like i
get to do it now but then
exactly uh around here did you think you
were winning no because she has king g6
yeah i thought here i already i i felt
like i already let everything go at this
point but i thought i have like king g6
maybe i can go
like queen b8 or something
i mean she has no time like i also have
no time i felt like something would
happen eventually okay
and but you did seize the moment
and because you know we're going to ask
you why
[Laughter]
what you did was a forced mate which is
great
yeah what's the problem
but we did see you shake your head yeah
when you didn't take the rook with jack
because i just assumed she went king you
have someone and then i'm going to go
quincy someone queen bee and then but
then i realized the king is actually on
f8 and i was like wait a minute like
what happened
beautiful
boy you sure you sure fooled our
commentating team
very nice uh
tada focus you've got a big playoff
coming up and good luck thank you
absolutely well a big bounce back there
both for ray robson and tata